We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Morris. You probably all heard that this American life episode called When Patent's Attack about innovation, stifling, tech industry,
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球排名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州和全球范围内合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这一切都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。欲了解更多信息，请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。你们可能都听过那期名为《当专利发起攻击》的《美国生活》节目，内容是关于创新、扼杀、科技行业、
patents, and patent trolls. Oh, it's so good. It's so good. If you haven't heard it, you should just go listen to it right trolls. Oh, it's so good. It's so good. If you haven't heard it, you should just go listen to it right now. I'll wait. Choo. Let's see what's on the internet.
专利和专利流氓。哦，太棒了。真的太棒了。如果你还没听过，你应该现在就去听。我会等你的。嘘。让我们看看网上有什么。
All right. Now, you don't really have to have heard the TAL show, but it gives an interesting backdrop to what you're about to hear. because it's horrible and egregious as patent enforcement and lawsuits are today. They rarely result in murder. But things were different in 1879. That's when a hounded and pursued patent violator struck back, it made it possible for average working people
好了。现在，你其实不必非得听过那期节目，但它为你即将听到的内容提供了一个有趣的背景。因为尽管今天的专利执行和诉讼是如此可怕和令人震惊，但它们很少导致谋杀。但在1879年情况却不同。那时，一位饱受折磨和追捕的专利侵权者进行了反击，这使得普通劳动人民
to afford quality dentures. It's a very historically significant murder. I mean, anyone who ever gets dentures, I mean, he was indirectly affected by this crime. That's John Mar. My name's John Mar. The editor and publisher of the fanzine murder can be fun.
能够负担得起高质量的假牙。这是一起具有历史意义的谋杀案。我的意思是，任何戴假牙的人，我的意思是，他都间接受到了这起犯罪的影响。那是约翰·马尔。我叫约翰·马尔。是《谋杀可以很有趣》这本杂志的编辑和出版人。
Before the 1850s, dentures were made at a very hard, very painful and very expensive material, like gold or ivory. They were a luxury item. But the invention of vulcanite, hard rubber changed everything. It was moldable, it could be precisely fitted, and it was relatively cheap. Everyone began making dentures with vulcanite. And these dentures had been overwhelmingly popular. But then in 1864,
在19世纪50年代之前，假牙是由非常坚硬、非常痛苦且非常昂贵的材料制成的，比如黄金或象牙。它们是奢侈品。但硫化橡胶的发明改变了一切。它具有可塑性，可以精确贴合，而且相对便宜。每个人都开始用硫化橡胶制作假牙。这些假牙非常受欢迎。但后来在1864年，
a long disputed patent application originally filed a dozen years earlier in 1852 was awarded and then acquired by the Good Year Dental Vulcanite Company. It was a company created to collect fees or very often sue dentists who already used Volcanite and there were plenty of dentists to go after. And the person that went after them was named Josiah Bacon, the treasurer of the Good
一项长期存在争议的专利申请（最初于12年前的1852年提交）获得了批准，随后被固特异牙科硫化橡胶公司收购。这是一家为了收取费用或经常起诉已经使用硫化橡胶的牙医而成立的公司，而且有很多牙医可以作为目标。而那个追捕他们的人名叫约西亚·培根，是固特异牙科硫化橡胶公司的财务主管。
Year Dental Volcanite Company. The Good Year Volcanite from their patent from the dentist. The Good Year Volcanite Company now monopolized the market. Dense us were required to buy their rubber and other contraptions used to make denture bases from them, and there were heavy taxes and fees associated with all of this. The price just kept going up and up. Josiah Bacon was crisscrossing the country, throwing dentists in jail, extracting fees, fines, setting up sting operations. He is a very busy man, very enthusiastic about enforcing his patent.
固特异硫化橡胶公司从牙医那里获得了专利。固特异硫化橡胶公司现在垄断了市场。牙医被要求从他们那里购买橡胶和其他用于制作假牙基托的装置，所有这些都伴随着沉重的税收和费用。价格一直在上涨。约西亚·培根在全国各地奔波，把牙医关进监狱，榨取费用、罚款，并设置诱捕行动。他是一个非常忙碌的人，对执行他的专利非常热衷。
It was reported and disputed that Bacon's zero for enforcing the patent may have been more his personal mission than that of the good your Volcanite company. He had rigged the deal so he actually personally got the money. I don't know how much the details, but it sounds like a very unusual financial arrangement with the company. Enter Samuel Shelfant, a dentist who made dentures and who didn't pay the good year of old-night company for the privilege. And Josiah Bacon was out to make an example of him. Josiah Bacon had chased Shelfant out of them Delaware, out of them St. Louis, and finally
据报道并有争议的是，培根对执行专利的热情可能更多是他个人的使命，而不是固特异硫化橡胶公司的使命。他操纵了这笔交易，以至于他实际上个人获得了这笔钱。我不知道细节，但这听起来像是与该公司的一种非常不寻常的财务安排。塞缪尔·谢尔凡特登场了，他是一位制作假牙的牙医，他没有为使用硫化橡胶向固特异公司付费。而约西亚·培根一心想拿他杀鸡儆猴。约西亚·培根把谢尔凡特从特拉华州赶走，从圣路易斯赶走，最后
in San Francisco, and he was swearing he was going to send him to prison. Samuel Shelfand was completely beaten down by this relentless pursuit and claimed that he went to Josiah Bacon to San Francisco Hotel Room on Easter Sunday 1879 to make peace, to pay whatever he could, and just go back to being a simple dentist. However, Shelfant, he had a gun in his pocket. And as he says, he argued with Bacon, Bacon Threatness and in prison, to command some respect, Shelfant pulled the gun and as guns that you wave in front of your enemies always do, it went off.
在旧金山，他发誓要把他送进监狱。塞缪尔·谢尔凡特被这种无情的追捕彻底击垮了，声称他在1879年复活节那天去了约西亚·培根在旧金山的酒店房间求和，想尽其所能支付费用，然后回去做一个简单的牙医。然而，谢尔凡特口袋里有一把枪。正如他所说，他与培根争吵，培根威胁要让他坐牢，为了赢得尊重，谢尔凡特掏出了枪，正如你在敌人面前挥舞枪支时总是会发生的那样，枪走火了。
Samuel Shelfant murdered Josiah Bacon. Shelfant was like extremely upset. He sat in the hotel suite, waiting for people to come in to capture him. Everyone was down at breakfast, so he slipped out of the hotel. And he wanted to run the city and took a room in a cheap, grooming house
塞缪尔·谢尔凡特谋杀了约西亚·培根。谢尔凡特非常不安。他坐在酒店套房里，等着人们进来抓他。大家都去吃早餐了，所以他溜出了酒店。他想逃离这座城市，在一家廉价的寄宿公寓里开了一间房，
and just kind of laid in bed for a couple days, you know, guilty, feverish, distraught, and then he turned himself into the police. He made a statement to the police where he said that he had shot them, bacon accidentally. And the police believed he was sincere thinking that he'd have to come up with some story better than that if it was truly premeditated. However, when it came time for a trial, the prosecution had this man marching in the hotel room of his bittersd enemy with a loaded gun in his pocket. The consensus was he was very lucky to get off with a 10-year sentence
躺在床上待了几天，你知道，感到内疚、发烧、心烦意乱，然后他向警方自首了。他向警方发表了一份声明，说他是意外射杀了培根。警方认为他是真诚的，认为如果是蓄意谋杀，他肯定会编造一个比这更好的故事。然而，当审判开始时，检方指出此人是带着装满子弹的枪走进他死敌的酒店房间的。普遍的看法是他非常幸运，只被判了10年监禁
for second-degree murder. He actually had a very good gig in prison. He was the prison dentist. He had an office outside the walls Or actually most importantly, he didn't have to work in the jute mill making burlap sacks like most of the other poor guys did The only part of the prison uniform he had to wear were striped trousers his patients who weren't on convicts He could collect fees from for being in San Quentin. He had it pretty good But nonetheless, he just found it enormously oppressive and was quoted as saying that he would almost have preferred to have gone
因为二级谋杀罪。他在监狱里其实过得不错。他是监狱的牙医。他在围墙外有一个办公室，或者最重要的是，他不必像其他大多数可怜人那样在黄麻厂制作粗麻袋。他唯一需要穿的监狱制服部分是条纹裤子。他可以向那些不是囚犯的病人收取费用。在圣昆廷监狱，他过得相当不错。但尽管如此，他还是觉得这极其压抑，并被引用说他宁愿选择
to the gallows. Then it just be blocked up in a cell for 15 hours out of 24. Shalfon had a female admirer on the outside, fighting for his release by normal legal means. But it was alleged that she also tried to get him out of prison through less than legal means. Someone slipped in some non-striped trousers, railroad tickets, some money and some pistols, bag of laundry, and he snuck out with a crowd of visitors taking the boat back to the city. And before they noticed he was gone, he was safely in sconce on a Utah-bound train.
去绞刑架，也不愿在24小时内被关在牢房里15个小时。谢尔凡特在外面有一位女性崇拜者，通过正常的法律手段为他的释放而斗争。但据称，她也试图通过非法的手段让他出狱。有人塞进了一些非条纹裤子、火车票、一些钱和几把手枪，装在洗衣袋里，他混在游客群中溜了出去，坐船回到了城市。在他们发现他失踪之前，他已经安全地坐上了开往犹他州的火车。
The only reason he was caught, he had disguised himself with some whiskers, but he was eating a peach while they were crossing Nevada. And the juice from the peach loosened the gum, holding his whiskers enough that a rail detective spotted that this guy looked kind of suspicious. He was detained in Nevada. He never made a pass when a maca.
他被抓的唯一原因是他用胡须伪装了自己，但在穿过内华达州时，他正在吃桃子。桃子的汁液弄松了粘住胡须的胶水，以至于一名铁路侦探发现这家伙看起来有点可疑。他在内华达州被拘留。他再也没能去成。
guy look kind of suspicious. He was detained in Nevada. He never made a pass when a maca. Even though he got caught escaping, he was later pardoned and only spent six years in prison when he got out. He returned to San Francisco and was a very successful dentist until he retired shortly before the earthquake. But it must have felt kind of weird making Volcanite dentures. In doing my research, I found a directory of professional men of San Francisco from the 1890s.
这家伙看起来有点可疑。他在内华达州被拘留。他再也没能去成。尽管他因逃跑被抓，但他后来获得了赦免，只在监狱里待了六年。他出狱后回到了旧金山，并成为了一名非常成功的牙医，直到地震前不久退休。但制作硫化橡胶假牙一定让他感觉很奇怪。在做研究时，我发现了1890年代旧金山专业人士名录。
And there was a half page in there on him and it talks about his education, his experience in serving the Civil War. But it makes absolutely no mention of rubber dentures, chasai bacon, or the Vulcanite Company. But this extreme case of anti-patent role of vigilantism or cold blood murder, however you want to view it, did have an effect. The good your Vulcanite Company stopped enforcing their patent. Apparently none of their employees was really unwilling to take a chance
里面有半页关于他的介绍，谈到了他的教育、他在内战中的经历。但完全没有提到橡胶假牙、约西亚·培根或硫化橡胶公司。但这种极端的反专利流氓的治安维持行为，或者冷血谋杀，无论你怎么看，确实产生了影响。固特异硫化橡胶公司停止了执行他们的专利。显然，他们的员工中没有人真的愿意冒着
of being shot by a dentist. And there's also the implication that sort of this whole denture patent was kind of a jaziah bacon's personal project more than it was major policy of the companies. In the patent last most of the world forgot about Samuel Schauffant but the late 19th century dental profession learned from their bitter experience in what they considered the Vulcanite rubber patent reign of terror. They collectively positioned themselves so that they could no longer be milked
被牙医枪杀的风险。而且还有一种暗示，即整个假牙专利与其说是公司的主要政策，不如说是约西亚·培根的个人项目。在专利过期后，世界上大多数人都忘记了塞缪尔·谢尔凡特，但19世纪末的牙科专业人士从他们痛苦的经历中吸取了教训，他们称之为硫化橡胶专利的恐怖统治。他们集体调整了立场，以便不再被
by any profiteering patent holders. Many years later, a similar scheme was put into motion to try to collect royalties for gold crowns, and the Deadwood Association killed it easily without firing a single shot. angle shot. 99% Invisible was produced this week by me Roman Mars. It was based off the story by John Mar from his fanzane murder can be fun. The great, rate of life changing fanzane murder can be fun.
任何牟取暴利的专利持有人所剥削。多年后，类似的计划被付诸实施，试图为金冠收取版税，而死木协会甚至没有开一枪就轻松地将其扼杀了。99%隐形本周由我罗曼·马斯制作。它基于约翰·马尔从他的杂志《谋杀可以很有趣》中讲述的故事。伟大的、改变生活的杂志《谋杀可以很有趣》。
It's not a website. It's on paper. Ask appearance. Special thanks to Plastics Historian Julie Robinson. Yes, there is such things as a Plastics Historian. And her name is Julie Robinson. This program is made possible with support from Lunar, making a difference with creativity. It's a project of KALW-91.7 local public radio in San Francisco, the American Institute of
它不是一个网站。它是在纸上的。询问外观。特别感谢塑料历史学家朱莉·罗宾逊。是的，确实有塑料历史学家这种职业。她的名字叫朱莉·罗宾逊。本节目由Lunar支持制作，用创造力创造差异。这是旧金山KALW-91.7当地公共广播电台的一个项目，美国建筑师协会
Architects in San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. This program is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public by now more at PRX.org. This week and every week I am helped by a superstar intern Sam Greenspan. If you see him in the home wipe time on the back, buy him a cup of coffee. I know you're listening to PR. But you know I still know. It's pretty soon. I think he's going to be our boss.
在旧金山，以及建筑与设计中心。本节目由PRX分发，公共广播交易所让公共广播更加公开，现在在PRX.org了解更多。本周和每周，我都有超级实习生山姆·格林斯潘的帮助。如果你在走廊里看到他，拍拍他的背，给他买杯咖啡。我知道你在听PR。但你知道我仍然知道。很快了。我想他会成为我们的老板。
You can find the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars. Or you can just catch up with us on the website. 99%Invisible.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Facebook上找到这个节目。我在推特上叫罗曼·马斯。或者你可以在网站上关注我们。99%Invisible.org。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。